rather than like from a purely
theoretical standpoint which I could do
I think it makes more sense just to
think about this function which is not
that unusual a function in most ways and
notice that it sort of pushes on the
boundaries of what we know about
calculus and forces us to think about
like to introduce new language into
differentiation like on it
okay so y equals the cube root of x now
the cube root of a number is different
to the square root of a number okay
because when you think about this
already
we were just laboring the point that the
square root of x right and the square of
X are not exactly opposite to each other
and they're not exactly opposites
because when you square something you
lose its sign and then when you take a
square root the sign doesn't just
magically reappear okay so these two I'm
not exactly matched up let's just think
about this visually for a second maybe
you just want to do a very small sketch
on the side of this if we put these on a
couple of them
it's an axis okay why cause it's square
we've done this one yeah hey there's
Mike was x squared out now familiar old
parabola what happens with the square
root of x is that you get something like
a parabola but you really get half of it
yes
okay so if I want to get this bottom
part down here then that well let's just
actually put these equations on let me
tell you what I've just drawn is y
equals the square root of x okay what
would correspond to it on the bottom
would be y equals the negative square
root of x okay which is why if you could
give an equation like okay x squared
equals 25
okay there are in fact two solutions to
this right and they are the plus and
minus square root of 25 which of course
is fine okay
so you can get both solutions if you're
squaring but if you're taking the square
root you're gonna gain to 1/2 we are
defining that as the positive side okay
but something more interesting passport
useful happens when you think about it
okay because take any one of you like
right let's go back to let's go back to
our example of flight if I do the cube
root of five cubes okay well five cubes
125 this is after you come back to fine
okay but if you take the cube root of
the cube of negative five think about
what happens okay so this in here is
minus five times minus 5 times minus 5
which is minus hundred twenty-five there
are three negatives in there right so
two of them cancel leave one behind okay
now what this means is once I clean up
my radical side is what's the number
that if you multiply it by itself three
times will give you negative 125 and
that is unambiguously that is negative
five so you do get back the same shape
okay or the same number I should say now
since you get the same number here you
are getting exactly the same shape over
here rather than just half of it okay so
now join me two sets of axes
we are familiar with what the cube of X
looks like right Oh
on the right hand side for X grades here
it's just like x squared but steeper
right but because the cube of a negative
number is also negative right that's why
you're getting this kind of shape down
here okay
it's an odd function because it has an
odd power of course so in order to get
our shape of X cubed translated worked
out into what the cube root of x looks
like okay just think about this guy
think about this it order to make sure
we get everything oriented correctly
okay what you're really doing is you're
reflecting this shape I ignored this
part over here I get rid of it and if I
reflect it across this line y equals x
ok turn you head 45 degrees so you're
looking up that way and you flip it
across and you get this shape the square
root of x I want to do exactly the same
thing but with this it's thought I don't
need to cut out half of it because the
negatives are all fine ok and when I do
that he's the shape I get are you happy
with that have a think about it find out
y equals x line through there you turn
your head and then you reflect the whole
thing okay you're going to get see you
see that pot okay and then over here
in fact more or less I mean just like X
to the 4 and X to the 6 and X to the 8
will look like
steeper and flatter versions of this
right beyond the high odd powers sooner
I don't add any like other roots in the
Earth's past us to the origin like so
we'll just look like this except steeper
and more boxy okay so you can do the
same kind of transformation this one
here yes yes which is a really important
point now let's come come over than that
when I did my cube of X okay we see just
like with the square of X okay it slows
down right here and it's literally you
can work out we now have the tools to
work out the gradient at the origin
right now of course do you want DX in
this case is 2 X so therefore when x
equals 0 you're grading is also 0
flatline okay your gradient here your
rate function I should say will be 3 x
squared so again at the origin you're
getting 0 does that make sense so a
horizontal tangent now have a look at
this guy okay because everything all the
X's and Y's have been swapped as it were
okay what you used to be a horizontal
tangent is a vertical tangent exactly
right in fact it's it's the y-axis right
it's the y-axis but this is a bit weird
this is a bit strange cuz think about
like you've just told me by this is what
for unison safe by inspection oK you've
got a vertical tangent there how would
we normally go about finding the
equation of a tangent
what's our normal process if I say I've
got a curve I want the equation of
attainder a particular what we do we're
gonna leave a different shape and then
dew point gradient and get an equation
of a line down let's give it a shot
let's see what happens let's go
so y equals cubed x what's a nice neat
way to write that so differentiating is
easy so when I work out my derivative
it's just the power law yeah so my
powers gonna come out the front comes
the coefficient and then what happens to
the power we subtracted one we went
through first principles I'll show that
you could do this with fractional stuff
as well now this because there's a
negative in the industry you need X
right what does that mean about the
whole thing yeah it's on the denominator
right so this is really one on three X
to the two thirds okay so this is a
problem for us because at zero zero
which is where I was interested in the
origin I plus through there right but it
zero zero what's the derivative equal to
the derivative is undefined in fact
that's what I would write dy DX is
undefined it's not infinity it's not
infinity one over zero is not infinity
it doesn't have a value right you can't
put any number on it and then do maths
on it that's coherent it breaks all the
rules okay including infinity so it's
undefined and that shouldn't be
surprising because as you told me before
the tangent is a vertical line what's
the gradient of a vertical line it's
under focus doesn't have a run there's
no run on the denominator rights at
every kind of divide so what can we say
about this thing this graph here okay um
the cube root of x is continuous at 0 0
right there's no breaks in the curve
it's nice and smooth I don't have to
pick up my pen but it's not and you
can't find a derivative right you can't
differentiate and evaluate at that point
so we say is it's not differentiable you
can't differentiate it at that point of
course you can differentiate in a whole
bunch of other points right in fact
every other point just that one that's
the problem
ok vertical tangents give you this issue